welcome back former president trump said
he would pull u.s troops from
afghanistan by may 1st
but joe biden's taking his time
announcing today that he will pull
troops by the 20th anniversary
of the attacks on september 11th joining
me now is general jack keane fox news
senior strategic
analyst general thanks so much for being
with me tonight
great to be here lawrence uh general
obviously
i am excited about this because it has
been
far too long but i i want to start by
first talking about where he's making
the announcement
an arlington cemetery
what is your reaction to the place where
he's making that announcement
and the announcement itself of our truth
finally coming home
well i don't have any view on where he's
making the announcement
public policy is his choice and where he
chooses to do it i fundamentally
disagreed with president trump in
announcing a one may withdrawal although
he did have in mind that there would be
certain conditions
before the united states would withdraw
and that would be
hopefully we would have a peace
agreement negotiated between the afghan
government and the taliban
and also a cease-fire we don't have any
of that we have
stalemated negotiations
secondly the taliban has increased the
level of violence
uh in the country itself so the taliban
sees
uh that there's political weakness here
in the united states in terms of the
resolve to stay and they've been
obviously taken advantage of that
situation i think this decision is
misguided
because it's reckless and it's also
shameful
it's shameful because we're abandoning
the afghan government
and in my mind it's a surrender to the
taliban
yeah it's reckless because why why are
we still there
what what are we really doing there well
first of all we're not
fighting a conventional war as people
are ascertaining we are
we haven't done that since 2014 when we
pulled all the combat troops out
but what are these few thousand troops
doing there
they're there in afghanistan for the
same reason
that we have troops in four other places
where we believe radical islam will do
harm to us
there's 40 or 50 movements of radical
islamists around the world
we're not chasing any of those but
multiple presidents have said
we have a problem in syria with isis
re-emerging
let's make certain we that does not
happen and we have a few hundred troops
there we have troops in
in iraq for the same reason and that's a
couple thousand
it's classified the number that's
targeting the al-qaeda in yemen
but they have aspirations also to attack
america
we have seven or 800 troops in eastern
africa
because that radical islamic
organization al-shabaab has
aspirations to attack america that is it
and the 3 000 troops in afghanistan are
there for the very same reason
the potential rise of al qaeda which was
the place
where they attacked us from 9 11 and
make certain that isis which has grown
in the country
does not do that most of us who look at
that say
my that's a modest investment to get
such a positive gain out of that but
that's
an insurance policy that the united
states is not going to be attacked again
you know general
i have immense respect for you and you
are an expert on this
issue but the majority of the country
doesn't feel that way
and many ask the question because
there's always a chance of a vacuum
opening
and terrorists coming back and forming
some other group
when will they ever leave then
well the terrorists haven't left the
battlefield lawrence
and that's we don't we don't keep the
american people informed and advised is
what's going on
none of our presidents have ever done a
very good job of doing that
and and the the facts are they're still
out there
and as i said i think what we have done
and what we have matured and evolved to
is a very specific and focused threat
on only those groups that have
aspirations to hurt
america and the american people and it
is a
modest involvement in doing that
and it's a complete distortion about
talking about
this major war that we're involved in in
afghanistan it's just not the case
so general and i have to go but if i
could get a quick response to you
is it no longer a strategy of the united
states to
change hearts and minds there is that no
longer there
i don't know when we ever had that
strategy we went there
to kill the taliban who would not give
up the al-qaeda
which we did summarily and depose that
regime and then run the al-qaeda into
their holes
and kill as many of them as we can and
we did that
what we didn't do is we got deflected by
the war in iraq
and we did not follow the hokkaido
across the border into pakistan and
finish the job
is what we should have done so there's
other policies that got in the way
yeah thank you so much general i
appreciate your insight
yep yeah good talking to you